and as he continues to battle pancreatic
cancer uh Alex Trebek got emotional when
he read a contestants answer in Final
Jeopardy prove you're smiling I like
that let's take a look at your response
did you come up with the right one no
what is we love you out that's very kind
thank you Kashia 1995 you're left with
the five bucks okay oh and you know I
know his heart was in the right place
when he did that but you can see the
look on the contestants face when he
realized that he just made Alex cry and
he feels bad for it like it's like we've
talked about Alex Trebek like going
through this journey and he has been so
in a way professional bow down and so
even like you he's going back he's still
doing jeopardy every day even says like
sometimes he's really struggling
backstage before he comes out but he
pulls it together and does jeopardy so I
think I think he these days she's
probably he's still motional going
through so much but yeah he's putting on
that front and so yeah that's just
managed to break him just for a second
but yeah it's so powerful to see this is
Alex getting emotional made me emotional
I mean facing his own mortality who
humbly doesn't know just how loved and
appreciate he is angry bird says now I'm
choked up angry bird says he's getting
choked up I know it says it was so sweet
to see Alex get choked up pollicis
praying for Alex yeah
[Music]